[Musique]
alors quand tout a commencé comme ça,
j'étais évidemment super nerveux à propos
de ce qui se passait et de ce que nous
aurions si vous obteniez un
diplôme ou si nous pouvions voir nos
amis avant la fin de l'année scolaire, mais
je m'attendais un peu à un
diplôme virtuel ou peut-être pas un du tout, mais
pour qu'ils aiment assembler tout cela
et pouvoir monter jusqu'à grand-mère
et prendre des photos et aussi voir des gens
comme passer. Je
n'en ai pas un virtuel
et c'était en personne que je pouvais voir tous
comme mes professeurs et mon directeur, puis
recevoir mon diplôme en personne, nos enfants
méritent quelque chose de spécial et nous ne
voulions pas avoir juste un diplôme virtuel
ou nous ne voulions pas faire juste un
drive-in, nous voulons faire quelque chose
de spécial et c'est vraiment symbolique de
la vallée du mont Washington
[Musique]